okay today I'm going to talk to you
about percentile charts percentile
charts is type of growth chart that
monitors children's growth over time
this allows us to see if their
development is normal and healthy or
whether there needs to be some kind of
medical intervention so what we're going
to do is to see how this works so first
of all let's think what it actually
means for percentile so let's just
imagine well this is just a real kind of
rough diagram to show the different mass
of different babies so let's say there's
a million babies born in a particular
country over the course of a year some
of those babies will be very very small
so here's right are really little and of
a kind of of our light mass or low mass
some babies will kind of be average kind
of size average mass and we're going to
get some really bigger babies as well so
what we can see is we've got a huge
range of different sizes now there'd be
all of the different babies in between
as well and a kind of sliding scale if
we arrange them from the lightest to the
heaviest but I'm not going to draw all
of those in right now but just imagine
we've got a nice sliding scale to show
the smaller babies at this end and the
much bigger babies at this end so what a
percentile is is essentially what we do
is we split up all of these different
masses of babies into a hundred
different groups
that's what percent means sent whenever
you sit here and see the word sense we
think of a hundred so there's a hundred
different groups so the very very
lightest group would be percentile one
so for example if there were a million
babies in our sample size 1% of a
million is ten thousand so there'd be
ten thousand babies in this first
category there'd be ten thousand in the
second and ten thousand in this third
all the way up right in the middle the
50th percentile what that means is fifty
percent of babies are at least this mass
or bigger and fifty percent of babies of
this mass or less and right up to the
very
the very heaviest group would be that
100th percentile so we've got all of
this data now what we do with this is we
can actually track the babies kind of
development over time and this is where
the percentile chart comes in along the
x-axis we have age of the baby in months
up the y-axis what we have is the mass
of the baby in kilograms so we can see
how that changes over time so let's
first of all consider our really light
babies let's say our very first
percentile now they might start around
here and over time they're going to
increase in mass as they grow so we
should expect to see a growth like that
with our heavier babies we're going to
obviously start at a higher mass so
maybe they're and they're going to grow
over time as well now these numbers are
only approximate please don't take them
as as the real values for the first
100th percentile now a 50th one would go
somewhere in the middle so it would look
like this because what we can see is the
average kind of development of these
different groups over time so what's the
point of the growth chart we can see
this right now now if I've quickly show
you how to read this first of all let's
see at 6 months what each of these
difference percentiles way so the
average must in the sixth in the first
percentile so I just write the different
ones down here there's our first
percentile there's our 50th percentile
and there's a hundredth percentile so
the average mass of a baby in the SiC in
the first percentile after six months is
around approximately approximately 6
kilograms so all you need to do is read
up to the line and then across to the
y-axis so it's 6 months and the 50th
percentile according to this will be
around about 9 kilograms and after six
months and 100 percentile would be just
under 12 kilograms ok so that's how to
read a growth chart no it's
far as medical intervention goes doctors
will normally intervene for three
different things first of all if it's if
the baby is above the hundredth
percentile or below the first percentile
then there may well be something to look
at so if the baby
at any stage is either side of these
lines development is very very irregular
and therefore they need to look at look
into it there could be a problem with
malnutrition or
over nutrition basically needs to be
looked at secondly if there's two or
more so two plus percentile line changes
over time then we also need to look into
it something else is probably not going
quite right for example in the first
percentile if we start off here but then
have an unexpected growth spurt that
could be that could be problematic
similarly if we started off where we'd
expect to be going looking at the rest
of the percentile it shifts by two or
more percentiles the other way they
could be a problem with malnutrition
here as well the third way that we might
have an intervention of some sort is if
there's an inconsistent pattern so my
development might be going up and down
or a bit all over the place an example
of this could be from a small baby with
a very large head
so percentile charts allow us to monitor
the growth of babies over time to see if
they need help if one of these three
things happen and what a percentile is
is it's just the whole population split
up and put in order from the lightest to
the heaviest of the lightest mass to the
greatest mass and every single
percentile is a hundredth of the full
number thank you